à deux pas de la plage drm font leur
entrée
elles ont été élus dans leur commune
nous rencontrons la femme canne à sucre
la déesse de la mer la poupée en
feuilles de bananes en ce lundi gr7 aux
anses d'arlet qu'elles ont choisi de
parader s'il faut faire comment 10 pour
les communes ont bien participé faire le
vide et tous les jours est épuisant
caroline vié coquilles de nos
personnages traditionnels du carnaval en
fait les frais tous les jours ma femme a
chip obama chipoter pour ans lundi gras
très peu de mariages burlesques plutôt
un vrai couple qui n'ose pas encore se
prononcer en attendant voilà qu'en aval
on va attendre mon mariage se marient
les magnifiques jolie et sexy
allez cette fois on rentre dans le vide
et voici un petit aperçu
en satin avec une musique un peu plus
gai et entraînant
ah bon on peut le local un peu
d'ici avec des cuivres peut-être vidéo
coup plus construit donc voilà ça n'a
l'air bien j'ai pas c'est la première
fois que je viens voir le carnaval
bon sans plus je pensais qu'il y avait
plus de si vous voulez plus de chance
mais bon vous ratés sur votre faim je
reste sur ma faim effectivement
réactions mitigées pour le carnaval aux
anses d'arlet peut-être parce que ce
n'est qu'un début pour la commune